hello everyone and welcome to another
really impressive game uh also from the
second day of the rapid and blitz uh in
paris this is the blitz section of
course and it is the last day of the
blitz again
wesley saw now faces 11 uh aaron or
rather he faces wesley so as it says
here
uh let me just fix that real quick uh
there we go uh so wesley faces levon
and uh he uh finds in a really an equal
in well just uh thriving in chaos both
of them
really enjoy complicated positions and
both of them really want to create and
uh
if you've watched levon's games he's
either on the receiving end of the
brilliancy or on the giving end of the
brilliancy
but there is always a brilliance
involved and this game
is no different so let's see what
happens uh when two players
who love to complicate meet over the
board or um
you know or online but but in this case
over the board
so here wesley with the white pieces
opens with d4
uh we have knight to f6 c4 we have uh
uh e6 knight to f3 and d5 so just a
normal queen scan but the klein knight
to c3 and bishop to b4
uh the aragos in defense is on the board
we have queen to a for
check and now black has to block with
the knight so he doesn't lose the bishop
and e3 now and this is uh basically
every fourth game we cover is
this opening it's very popular we have
castles
bishop to d2 and now d captures in c4
bishop captures and bishop back to d6
now so black wastes the temple
to bring the bishop back if white
decides to castle king side the bishop
will be very useful there
and so white wastes the tempo to shift
the queen over to c2 then the bishop can
retreat to d3 and you're going to put
some pressure on black's king's side
uh and here black plays a very
principled move white king is still in
the center of the board and he strikes
in the center with e5 you want to open
up
the position so you can start an attack
against the white king if uh
the king remains in the center of the
board so here
uh the captures on e5 we have knight
captures knight characters and the
bishop captures and interestingly
uh wesley and levon already had this
position this year it was in the
super bad chess clack classic that was
played in bucharest uh and that game
ended in a draw but in that game uh
wesley castled queen side but here he
plays a very interesting move he plays
f4 and now he asks what do you want to
do do you want to go back
or will you allow this pawn to remain
here and then i can play some maybe h3g
for g5 action
and really start attacking your king
side so levon says nope
let's take advantage of your king being
in the center of the board i'm just
going to
give up my bishop here bishop captures
and now comes
rook to e8 uh sorry not rook to eat
right queen to e7
preventing the king from castling
because the e3 pawn will fall
but this is exactly what wesley does he
doesn't sacrifice one pawn he sacrifices
two pawns he says queen side castles and
now this pawn will fall with
check and then this pawn will fall so
what compensation does wesley have well
let's see
levon accepts the challenge he plays
queen captures on e3 with
chuck king to b1 and now queen captures
an f4 with
checks so levon is now up two pawns and
if he can activate his pieces then
that's pretty much it uh but wesley says
you will not be able to act for your
pieces i have a monster
monster bishop player here my queen is
beautifully positioned i can bring my
rooks into the game very easily maybe
even do some rook lifts
and it should be a successful attack so
let's see
uh how wesley continues this he starts
with bishop to d3
now already you uh feel that something
is happening here like you can play
bishop capture spawn capture so you will
remove the defender of the h7 pawn
and then you can capture maybe with
chicken maybe you can get some sort of
an attack going
but levon says bishop to e6 uh the one
would be
very happy if wesley would do this for
example just bishop captures
and then after queen captures you grab
upon king h7
and fine uh levon developed a piece uh
he he gave back one pawn he's still up
upon and he's uh
in a you know in a good position you
can't grab the pawn because the bishop
hangs
and if you move the bishop back then we
play c6 and
our pawns are defended so all is nicely
done here
but wesley knows that today is paul
morphy's birthday and of course what do
you do then
uh well activity above all so he starts
further activating his pieces
rook h uh sorry bishop to e6 and then
rook h2f1 now attacks the queen the
queen has to move
queen back to h6 and only now bishop
captures an f6 we have g captures now
the rook here prevents the queen from
capturing on f6
and now uh this is basically a sp spit
in the face
queen captures in c7 wesley doesn't just
grab this pawn he's also ready to
capture this pawn
and he doesn't care that he will open up
some lines uh for the attack because
uh well he's just gonna win back some
pawns and then he will have uh
he he will have a much faster attack
against the blacks king or
so he claims so here bishop to d5
defending this pawn here
and wesley says nope this is not how you
play
active chess and he plays bishop to f5
and bishop to f5 is such a nice
wastely move uh this bishop is just a
monster here
uh it frees up the d3 square for the
rook you can do this rook lift because
the bishop is guarding the f3 square but
now
rook to d3 is coming and then rook to g3
rook to h3
all this becomes possible so here uh
you can't for example if you play bishop
to g2 obviously you don't want to
open up lines in front of your own king
just rook g1 and that's it
if you defend it we can just play we can
just bring the queen back queen c2 now
with a double attack here we defend our
bishop
and the black will lose this very easily
so after bishop to f5 we have bishop to
c6 now
also as the bishop was under attack on
d5
and now comes rook to d3 and now
what do you play here the position is so
bad for black that there is only one
move levon can play
not to get it destroyed here so instead
of finding a move that
wins for wesley i tried to find the only
move that
doesn't uh you know gets
completely destroyed for levon while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not playing rook f2 e8 this is a move
you want to play but this is the move
that
in this position simply doesn't work and
for those of you who found rook
8 to e8 then congratulations this is the
move you have to play
it's not the move that levon played it's
just the move you have to play point is
that after this
rook moves here uh then the idea that
happened in the game doesn't work
uh but you'll see why here for example
rook g3 checking to h8 and then rook to
h3 now attacking the queen
and after the queen moves we're just
gonna capture on h7 uh
queen to g5 now rook captures an h7 king
to g8 and you are safe here there's no
way for white to continue the attack
uh white might try rook to h3 to win the
queen with rook to g3
but now you have looked at e3 preventing
this the queen is now guarding the e3
square
so if you found this then really
congratulations you are
you are an impeccable defender of uh
well
crazy possessions however levon played
rook f the e8 and this is such a natural
move to make you don't want to box your
king
in the in the uh corner of the board uh
you want to allow him to have at least
one more option and that is king to f8
but
this has one a huge drawback and that is
that the f7 pawn is no longer defended
and it seems like
why would you defend the f7 pawn well
that's that's how chess works here
wesley went for rook to g3
check and now the problem is you no
longer have this because now rook h3
attacks the queen queen g5 captures with
czech king here and now the rook does
not defend the f7 pawn queen captures on
f7 would be checkmate
so instead after rook to g3 king the f8
was played that's why levon moved to the
rook so he can play king to f8
but now comes the the the true beauty of
the position
uh queen to d6 with check and the black
king has no moves
you have to block with the rook but now
comes rook to e1
a second attack uh on the rook here rook
ate the e8 now defending the rook but
here
uh wesley just played rook g to e3 and
he was in this position animal 25 that
levon arunan resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
there is no way to defend the rook we're
just going to capture it
giving up the queen would be pointless
you still can't capture with this rook
it's pinned
and even if you try something like queen
to g5 maybe saying that okay if captures
maybe i can pick up this uh
bishop would check uh just g4 white
would laugh in your face and that's it
there there is no way to defend this
you're just
gonna suffer a severe material loss
so after rook gt3 levon resigned the
game and
yet another masterful game played by
wesley so who
who once again managed to you know
create chaos
from a position both of them know
extremely well and they've had it
on the position on the board this year
but wesley found
an improvement he was able to complicate
things and you know
levon simply enjoyed it too much and
then he got carried away
uh played uh you know uh freed up the
the wrong rook and
this is the result but really really
really incredible stuff
and i might even use this for the
thumbnail of the video
yeah and there you have it hope you guys
enjoyed it wesley uh still leading the
tournament i don't know
if it's still as nipple is very very
close and you know
they're still playing while i'm
recording this but uh if nothing changed
and wesley is still
leading the tournament so hope you guys
enjoyed it really an incredible game
i would like to thank abdul aziz
abdullahani uh james o'toole
philosophical questions youtube eric
lobel
and alexander williams and for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga indeed
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day